let's have a little word from that
eminent producer directors from Warner
Brothers mr. Frank Sinatra
thank you very much ladies gentlemen
this is it we shall fasten our seat
belts start the countdown because we are
about 20 seconds to blast-off in what
after 36 years is there the most
important single honor in the entire
world for those of us who are engaged in
the exciting and sometimes heartbreaking
business of putting the living image of
humanity on a beam of light the nominees
for the best picture of the year are
America America a scene of production
Warner Brothers Elia Kazan second
nomination for Best Picture is Cleopatra
20th Century Fox Wald arranger the third
How the West was won metro-goldwyn-mayer
Cinerama Bernard Smith lilies of the
field
rainbow production United Artists mr.
ralph milk
the final nominee is Tom Jones would
fall production United Artists Tony
Richardson
she nearly lost our bird John's pony
Richard
excepting for Tony Richardson David
picker
if Tony were here he'd undoubtedly say
that you're granting this award to him
was super Tony couldn't be here tonight
but on behalf of Tony and on behalf of
all of his associates at Wood ball films
and on behalf of myself and my
associates at United Artists we are most
grateful most appreciative my heart is
in my throat thank you so much
let's face it that's it very brief as
long as I can remember I've heard people
say that maybe many of the world's
problems might be solved if we got a
common language and judging from the
results here tonight I think we may be
well on the way to having one
and in closing I'd like to congratulate
naturally not only the nominees but of
course the winners
with one following thought when in
Hollywood lures the British in Romans do
goodnight